how to write a good issue in github
github is a main place for the yogin
face open source library and you should
always go there to report a bug or ask
for a new feature
for more general questions or to debug
your own code use the forums see the
video link below
it's very important to write good issues
as it will help the bug you uncovered
bifix in no time
for this video we've created a version
of transformers with a back
you can install it by executing this
command in a notebook remove the
exclamation mark to execute it in a
terminal
in this version the following example
fails
the error is rather cryptic and does not
seem to come from anything in our code
so it seems we have a back to report
the first thing to do in this case is to
try to find the smallest amount of code
possible that reproduces the work
in our case inspecting the traceback
we see the failure happens inside the
pipeline function when it calls
autotokenizer.form retrained
using the debugger we find the values
passed to that method and can thus
create a small sample of code that
hopefully generates the same error
it's very important to go through this
step as you may realize there are always
on your side and not a bug in the
library but it also will make it easier
for the maintainers to fix your problem
here we can play around a bit more with
code and the t0 happens for different
checkpoints and not just this one and
that it disappears when we use useful
sequel force inside our tokenizer call
the important part is to have something
that does not depend on any external
files or data
try to replace your data by fake values
if you can't share it
with all of this done we are ready to
start writing our issue
click on the button next to bug report
and you will discover that there is a
template to fill it should only take you
a couple of minutes
the first thing is to properly name your
issue don't pick a title that is too
vague
then you have to fill your environment
information
for the command provided by the
transformers library to do this
just execute it in your notebook or in
the terminal and copy paste the results
there are two last questions to fill
manually to which the answers are no and
no in our case
next we need to determine where to tag
there is a full list of usernames in the
template since our issue has to do with
tokenizers we pick the maintainer
associated with them
there is no point tagging more than
three people they will redirect you to
the right person if you made a mistake
next we have to give the information
necessary to reproduce the bug
we based our sample and put it between
two lines with three back six
so that is formatted properly
we also paste the full trace back still
between two lines of three backticks
lastly
we can add any additional information
about what we tried to debug the issue
at hand
with all of this you should expect an
answer to your issue pretty fast and
hopefully a quick fix
note that all the advice into this video
applies for almost every open source
project